j'entends leurs voix je vois là je vois
le visage les voyages habités par ses
personnages marie claire blais est
devenu une légende de la littérature
québécoise marie câble ace et fondateur
c'est un monument c'est immense pour moi
ce qui ressort principalement c'est la
qualité de terre le travail de la langue
l'extrême maîtrise ça me semble qu'il ya
très difficile à traverser mais à québec
en 1939 marie claire blais a marqué
notre imaginaire collectif dès l'âge de
20 ans avec un premier roman intitulé la
belle bête elle connaît la consécration
en 1966 lorsqu'elle reçoit le prix
médicis pour son roman intitulé une
saison dans la vie d'emmanuel je suis
très proche d'une session d'entraînement
c'est quand même ça pourrait se passer
en chine on désigne par tous et
je suis très sensible ces mêmes c'est
une oeuvre de jeunesse et je crois que
les garçons
en 60 ans de carrière marie claire blais
a écrit des pièces de théâtre de la
poésie et 30 romans dont le sourd dans
la ville et visions dana savent qu'est
ce que soif entamée en 1995 a été un
tour de force parce que c'est une oeuvre
qui donne le droit d'exister à beaucoup
de monde c'est une oeuvre qui a écrit ce
qu'on appelle celle qu'on appelle les
marginaux le marginal a les a écrits
avec tellement d'humanité avec tellement
de générosité en leur donnant une
importance puis une grande profondeur
poétique et philosophique
mais il faut récompenser les crimes elle
partageait sa vie entre le québec et la
ville de tes os aux états unis son
oeuvre a toujours été traversé par sa
compassion pour les plus démunis elle
n'est pas sûre de vouloir welmant de
l'humain par l'humain
7e qui avait lui même et
on ne peut pas rester dans cet état
violence
être un humain dell annonce de son décès
les hommages sont venus de partout
rencontre du premier ministre du canada
et du premier ministre du québec je
pense qu'on va plus parler de marie
claire blais maintenant qu'avant
j'espère que ça va être l'occasion de
ramener beaucoup de ses oeuvres de
l'avant je suis un simple écrivain qui
travaillent un bleu non chez soi et
lectrices et observatrice infatigable
marie claire blais a écrit jusqu'à son
dernier souffle parce que la littérature
a été toute sa vie et parce que sa
littérature lui remplissait d'humanité
une phrase à la fois l'amour celle des
noirs ici louis fait depuis mai radio
canada montréal
[Musique]